when a massive star dies it can erupt in
a supernova for a split second it
outshines an entire galaxy but exactly
what causes them has been a mystery for
more than 50 years scientists can't just
look inside the star so the only way to
figure out what drives the explosion
known as a core collapse supernova is to
simulate it blowing up stars virtually
inside a computer
[Music]
the physics involved in supernova
explosions is complex and only with
modern super computers have physicists
been able to model the process in enough
detail to get stars to explode in 3d a
blast which in reality takes less than
half a second can take a supercomputer
six months to simulate but recent models
suggest that scientists are finally
getting close to understanding just what
it is that makes a supernova explode the
simulations start at the end of a star's
life having one low on hydrogen the star
starts to contract an iron core forms at
its center matter from the court then
collapses under gravity to form a
neutron star at its heart a ball the
size of a city but which packs in more
matter than the Sun
this is the stars core thousands of
times smaller than the star itself but
still a few hundred kilometers across
physicists think the collapsing matter
hits the neutron star at the center
sending a massive shockwave rebounding
outwards you can see the shockwave here
in like blue but then the wave meets
more falling matter it stalls and can't
escape the core the star doesn't explode
and that is where simulations used to
end
oceans go much further tiny
irregularities in the flow of matter can
quickly amplify into massive
oscillations these appears of violent
liquid like sloshing of matter around
the neutron star meanwhile neutrinos
particles produced within the neutron
star ferociously heat up the surrounding
matter causing it to churn and bubble
like water on a stove eventually the
intense heat of neutrinos combines with
the pressure of these violent motions
and drives out the shock wave the wave
accelerates out the core and explodes
into the star though all this takes less
than half a second the wave may take as
long as a day to reach the Stars surface
and create the spectacular fireworks we
see understanding this mechanism will
help astronomers to unpick other
important processes in the cosmos such
as how these violent explosions create
new atomic elements which are vital for
seeding fresh stars and planets though
physicists can't yet claim to have a
complete picture their simulations are
now good enough to compare with
real-life observations and if a
supernova went off today modern
detectors could measure more than ever
before detecting things like neutrinos
or gravitational waves which both sail
through matter unimpeded would allow
astronomers to see inside the exploding
star for the very first time but to make
sense of any of those data astronomers
need simulations and lots of them
scientists think that the last supernova
that blew up in our galaxy was in around
1870 but they tend to go off about twice
a century that means modelers need to
get their skates on
[Music]